oh the Emmy goes to RuPaul
this is the third consecutive nomination
and third consecutive win for RuPaul in
this category look at this thank you so
much television Academy everybody say
love now drive that down to 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue
so you just won and you're winning as a
host that's got to feel incredible for
your show it's great and you know I'm
just so happy that people enjoy our show
and enjoy the stories that we get to
tell because it's really about the
tenacity of the human spirit these kids
a lot of them come from nothing and and
the Society had pushed them to the side
on our show we celebrate them and to
become worldwide stars so I'm this is
really for all of them looking back on
your career as a hostess has to feel
incredible did you think that you would
get to this day where you're winning
not one but multiple Emmys no I never it
was never part of my budget to sort of
this part of it I was always a club
performer and I did what I needed to do
outside of the system but to have the
system acknowledge what we do at
RuPaul's Drag Race is really lovely and
I thank you for that well how are we
gonna top this next season what are we
in for oh you know what it's funny you
add drag queens to any situation and it
will handle itself it's gonna be really
good I've it's it's really good before I
let you go how are we celebrating where
is this gonna be at home well I'm gonna
put it in my office
honest on a beautiful shelf with the
other two that I have and I'm gonna
celebrate by living my life from this
day on to the fullest I'm gonna eat some
chicken I'm gonna dance I'm gonna laugh
I'm gonna love I'm going to sing I'm
gonna celebrate colors and I'm going to
enjoy life because that's my thank you
to God
baby RuPaul celebrating his big win
backstage at the creative arts Emmys I
have the answer for everybody
the answer is 36 24 36 and yes they are
real BAM where he and Michelle visage
spilled more secrets from their show on
the red carpet I mean every time it's
bigger and better
is there any guest judge or guest that
you'd like to come on I feel like you've
had so many what we love doing drag race
it's such a incredible show and people
are finding it around the world as we
speak through streaming services so it's
such a joy to do this show and present
so many courageous fabulous people to
young kids around the world who are in
small places who would never get a
chance to to witness that kind of
courage and fun and as far as guest
judges go Madonna would be a great guest
I feel like the people who love the show
or the people who belong there you
celebrate everything that we do then you
belong there we actually include it's an
inclusive show want everybody who wants
to be there part of it absolutely you
know all performers are drag queens you
know you never you know and once you
step onstage you take on a different
personality a different persona and all
of our guest judges understand that so
well you know no one is as who they
appear to be on camera so they are
especially equipped to judge drag queens
who are doing what they do tonight we're
honoring a lot of guest stars and we
have a lot of specials that are gonna be
receiving awards if you could have a
special about your own life what would
it be called it would go ruk ruk Palooza
and what are we going to touch out of
your life oh my goodness it's fun it's
and you know a life is only worth living
if you're having a lot of fun if you are
not doing what you do and inspiring all
of us what profession would you want to
take on I'd probably be a teacher a
teacher
would ya what level in school I really
don't know
I probably wouldn't matter I think it
would be all grades all levels I'd want
to teach about the beauty of life which
is music and laughing and dancing and
art and colors and love that's what
we're here for
[Applause]
[Music]